micro air vehicles present a very
appealing platform for search and rescue
civil engineering inspection and a
myriad of other task where it would be
difficult or dangerous to send a human
by flying over difficult terrain na vi's
skipped many of the most challenging
aspects of using a ground vehicle to
carry out these missions in environments
where GPS is available many researchers
have developed systems capable of high
level autonomous behaviors the robust
robotics group and the computer science
and artificial intelligence laboratory
at MIT has developed a micro air vehicle
capable of high level autonomous
behaviors and unconstrained GPS denied
environments we have outfitted a
quadrotor helicopter developed in
collaboration with ascending
technologies with a suite of sensors and
algorithms that successively closed the
loop and stabilize the vehicle in
unknown environments using a lightweight
laser scanner we are able to perform
high-resolution scan matching in real
time to estimate the vehicles relative
position these state estimates are
accurate enough that we can accurately
identify and locate a window in the 3d
point cloud generated from the raw laser
scans this narrow window not much wider
than the vehicle highlights the accuracy
and performance of our state estimation
and control algorithms the laser and
stereo camera allows us to perform
obstacle avoidance in 3d the real-time
state sensing and state estimation
algorithms provide us with a very stable
and robust platform on which to build a
suite of high level mapping and planning
capabilities that do not need to take
into account the fast and unstable micro
air vehicle dynamics we have integrated
the quadrotor with a slam solution that
allows us to map unknown environments
the map generated by the slam algorithm
also allows us to perform completely
autonomous exploration of unknown
environments the exploration module
seeks to balance learning the
geometrical extent of the environment
with sweeping known boundaries of the
map for a visual target this process
must also choose trajectories that
ensure the vehicle remains well
localized
this research culminated in our team's
entry into the 2009 auvsi international
aerial robotics competition the mission
was executed completely autonomously the
vehicle had to take off detect and fly
through a window explore an unknown
environment to find a designated control
panel using the onboard color camera our
vehicle completed the fifth mission in
the first year it was held a feat that
had not been achieved in the 19 year
history of the iarc competitions